ein alternder herrscher im kampf gegen
die zeit das erklärt sehr viel von dem
was wir im februar gesehen haben er hat
vor allem das gefühl keine zeit mehr zu
haben wenn es jetzt nicht macht dann
wird es in zehn jahren weniger russisch
sprechende menschen in der ukraine geben
eine stärkere armee so bleibt
aber warum hat er das getan
selbst die russen verstehen ihn nicht
mehr eines der mysterien dieses krieges
ist dass er für die russen noch
unerwarteter kam als für die menschen im
westen ich habe mit vielen russischen
kollegen gesprochen einige waren sehr
positiv putin gegenüber eingestellt
andere sehr kritisch aber alle glaubten
es sei ein blog es würde keinen krieg
geben
aus dieser sicht kam der krieg als
größere überraschungen für die russische
öffentlichkeit als für den westen